bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat à suivre cet
après-midi en séance
le débat organisé en présence de laurent
fabius le ministre des affaires
étrangères sur l'intervention des forces
armées françaises au mali depuis six
jours la france combat les rebelles
islamistes située au nord de cette
région
ce débat qui est organisée simultanément
à l'assemblée nationale intervient dans
un contexte difficile
après la mort dès le premier jour des
combats d'un officier français
il n'est pas suivi d'un vote mais ça
aurait pu être le cas selon la
constitution si le gouvernement décidé
de proroger l'intervention serval
au-delà des 4 noir ce fut d'ailleurs le
cas en 2011 pour l'intervention en libye
la grande majorité des sénateurs est
favorable à cette intervention militaire
mais certains comme le chef de file des
communistes pierre laurent regrette que
le parlement n'ait pas été consulté
avant l'envoi des troupes françaises au
mali de suite donc direction l'hémicycle
pour l'organisation de ce débat sur
l'intervention des forces armées
françaises au mali très bonne après midi
à tous sur public sénat monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre des
affaires étrangères mesdames et
messieurs les ministres à l'introduction
je voudrais tout d'abord me féliciter et
vous féliciter de la tenue de ce débat
il faut le dire avec honnêteté c'est un
des acquis de la révision
constitutionnelle de 2008 dont le texte
équilibré permet tout à la fois au
gouvernement d'agir et au parlement
d'être informé certains oublient cette
avancée significative qu'a pu
représenter ce texte
faut-il préférer un système à
l'allemande ou le bundestag doit
autoriser les moindres faits et gestes
du gouvernement en matière de défense
moi j'ai une conclusion toute simple
monsieur le premier ministre cinq heures
après la décision du président nos
soldats et qui est au combat les
polémiques que me semble stérile et
vaine
à l'heure du rassemblement républicain
autour de nos forces armées
notre diplomatie et notre défense ont
été à la hauteur de l'urgence et ont été
fidèles
je ne crains pas de le dire à l'image
que je me fais de la france membre
permanent du conseil de sécurité pays
qui disposent d'une vision globale des
enjeux internationaux
je salue l'action du président de la
république qui a su prendre lucidement
des décisions courageuses c'est la
france qui a fait prendre conscience à
la communauté internationale de la
gravité de la situation
c'est la france qui a été la cheville
ouvrière des trois résolutions des
nations unies c'est la france aussi qui
a su mobiliser ses partenaires européens
nous avons su agir en temps utile quels
sont les enjeux de l'intervention au
mali ce qui se produit mes chers
collègues normal in n'est pas un défi
pour les autorités de ce pays seulement
c'est une menace pour toute l'afrique de
l'ouest pour le maghreb pour l'europe et
pour le monde
le mali qui a cette frontière est une
clé dans la zone
le nid de frelons d'aqmi dans le désert
sahélien ne cessé d'étendre son champ
d'actions y compris vers le sud avec les
liens qui l'unissent à boko haram
quand un territoire grand comme une fois
et demie la france est maîtrisé par des
groupes terroristes
alors mes chers collègues nous sommes
devant une menace qui concerne
l'ensemble du monde nous ne pouvons pas
supporter ses mains coupées
ces femmes violées ces enfants déplacés
ces hommes lapidées ces soldats enfants
à brigade et nous ne pouvons pas
admettre que des monuments qui
représente les trésors de l'humanité
soit mis en pièces nous ne pouvons pas
accepter que le terrorisme et le
narcotrafic
puis se structurer sur un territoire
nous ne pouvons non plus admettre que
les preneurs d'otages soit les maîtres
du mali
nous ne pouvons laisser proliférer le
risque de contagion sur le territoire
européen
la france a agi sous mandat de la
communauté internationale elle a su
prendre ses responsabilités au service
du rétablissement de la paix et de
l'intégrité du mali est ce que ce sera
facile
un engagement militaire mes chers
collègues n'est jamais vous le savez au
moins aussi bien que moi une formalité
nous savons que quand une guerre est
lancée hélas sa logique propre qui
échappent parfois à notre volonté nous
savons que ce sera difficile
le sacrifice de la vie de nos soldats à
qui je rends ici hommage aux premières
heures de l'intervention vient nous le
rappeler cruellement
nous faisons face à des troupes
aguerries fortement armés extrêmement
mobiles bien entraînés et fanatisées qui
se dilue dans le désert et qui savent
mener des combats structuré dans une
région hostile qui leur est familière au
coeur de l'immense désert au relief
accidenté
nous connaissons la difficulté et les
pièges de la guerre asymétrique
j'ai confiance dans le professionnalisme
la qualité et la compétence de nos
forces armées qui ont su montrer sur
d'autres théâtres non moins exigeant
leur valeur je le redis aujourd'hui avec
force ma confiance
mon respect et mon estime notre
confiance
notre respect et notre estime devons
nous rester seul naturellement pas nous
agissons dans le cadre strict de la
légalité internationale et conformément
à la charte des nations unies et à la
résolution 20 85
cette intervention est tout sauf une
aventure française
nous avons reçu le soutien politique et
pratique de nombreux partenaires du
conseil de sécurité de l'union
européenne de l'union africaine de la
cedeao
oui l'algérie pays amis pays central a
un rôle clé dans la résolution de cette
crise son soutien actif nous est
indispensable
les capacités de renseignement de
communication de ravitaillement en vol
ou de transport de troupes de nos
partenaires nous seront très utiles
oui la france n'a pas vocation à agir
seul
car elle n'agit pas pour son propre
compte
la force africaine la misma est en cours
de constitution vous venez de nous le
rappeler monsieur le ministre des
affaires étrangères après l'urgence de
l'intervention
la priorité doit être de l'amener à son
niveau opérationnel le plus rapidement
possible l'union européenne doit jouer
un rôle central pour la mission de
formation de l'armée malienne qui
devrait aussi être accéléré monsieur le
ministre peut être nous dorer vous des
éléments de calendrier la sécurité de
l'afrique doit être bien sûr assurée par
les africains je me félicite donc de
l'action de l'union africaine et de la
cedeao
nous touchons du doigt l'importance de
notre coopération de défense structurel
avec les pays africains de nos écoles de
maintien de la paix et de notre
formation des cadres militaires
africains action qui dispose pourtant
dans notre budget de crédit dérisoire
très insuffisant nous le disons depuis
longtemps mais aussi cela résonne
aujourd'hui de façon toute particulière
certains disent ah là là il aurait fallu
négocier bien sûr mais négocie avec qui
s'il s'agit de forces politiques qui
veulent prendre leur part dans la
construction d'un avenir démocratique au
mali
oui mais négocie avec des groupes
terroristes
il ne peut pas en être question
l'offensive terroriste au sud a fait
tomber les masques
nous avions raison hélas sur en deçà
reding qui n'a cessé de souffler le
chaud et le froid pour finalement
révéler son vrai visage terroriste
odieux prônant l'application de la
charia sur tout le territoire malien et
asservissant les populations le m nla
dont nous avons reçu les représentants
il y à un mois et demi
l'un est évidemment un acteur
incontournable pour la résolution dans
le long terme de la question du nord
maltraité je le rappelle depuis des
décennies mais il est aujourd'hui
fragilisée bien sûr nous appelons à la
reprise du processus démocratique à une
solution négociée à une résolution
institutionnel de la question du
nord-mali mais quand la maison brûle
pardon de le dire de cette façon il faut
d'abord éteindre les incendies
au-delà de l'urgence sécuritaire le
processus politique de normalisation à
bamako mais aussi le processus de
réconciliation inter malienne doivent
reprendre
il reste plus que jamais essentiel que
les maliens adopte le plus rapidement
possible une feuille de route et créer
une structure de négociations avec les
groupes armés qui se disent aussi du
terrorisme
et ça commence nous ne pourrons pas
rebâtir la démocratie malienne à la
place des maliens le président hollande
de la bière laurent fabius l'a répété
tout à l'heure la france n'a pas
vocation à rester
est ce qu'il nous faut privilégier le
développement sur la guerre est ce qu'il
nous fallait le privilégié oui
certainement
seule une solution globale ou le
développement du nord trop longtemps
négligé en dépit des promesses et des
accords passés permettra la paix à long
terme mais nous savons aussi que le
développement est impossible sans
sécurité et sans démocratie notre action
militaire ne nous dispensera pas de
repenser notre politique de
développement pour tout le sahel
la france et l'europe s'y emploie avec
la stratégie de l'union européenne sur
le sahel
la première urgence sera de dominer la
crise alimentaire la seconde d'urgence
concernera les personnes déplacées
des centaines de milliers dans toute la
sous région
notre responsabilité est d'agir sur les
deux fronts à la fois éradiquer la
menace et trouver les moyens d'une
solution de long terme je voudrais pour
conclure vous livrer de réflexion
la première concerne les conséquences de
cette intervention
pardon d'y faire référence mais c'est
tellement d'actualité sur le format et
les équipements de notre armée à l'heure
où la commission du livre blanc tient
ses dernières réunions fait ses derniers
arbitrages
à l'heure où l'avenir de notre défense
va se jouer dans les prochains dans la
prochaine loi de programmation militaire
la crise malienne fait la démonstration
de la nécessité de disposer de moyens
capables de faire face à la diversité
des situations et des menaces un
éventail capacitaire large des forces
bien préparée bien équipé et capable de
durer
ses qualités sont encore celles de notre
armée elles permettent à la france de
concrétiser sa volonté
mes chers collègues ne baissons pas la
garde
notre commission l'a affirmé à maintes
reprises le format de nos armées est à
un niveau pardon de vous le dire juste
insuffisant en deçà ce serait le risque
de déclassement
nous avons aujourd'hui la démonstration
que la défense ne doit pas servir de
variable d'ajustement budgétaire le
président de la république l'a récemment
affirmé je le rappelle avec beaucoup de
force diminuer nos moyens militaires se
seraient diminués notre place dans le
monde
ce serait perdre en crédibilité
internationale
les dépenses de défense ne sont pas des
dépenses publiques comme les autres
elles sont les garantes de la sécurité
de nos concitoyens est la condition du
développement de notre pays
ne l'oublions pas elles sont aussi elle
qui à l'heure du redressement du pays
portent les ruptures technologiques l
innovation qui se diffusent ensuite dans
tout le tissu économique déterminante
je ne doute pas que cette intervention
militaire nous fasse mieux prendre
conscience collectivement de ces enjeux
majeurs
ma dernière réflexion porte sur l'impact
de cette intervention sur l'europe de la
défense
notre commission sénatoriale travail
avec ses homologues du triangle de
weimar plus sur la préparation du
conseil européen de décembre prochain
qui sera déterminant pour l'europe de la
défense
notre action au mali et les suites qui
lui seront données
mesdames et messieurs les ministres sont
une occasion de construire et de
relancer l'europe de la défense par des
réalisations concrètes et par
l'affirmation de notre communauté
d'intérêts et donc de notre solidarité à
cet égard c'est ensemble que les
vingt-sept ont décidé fin décembre
d'assurer la formation de l'allier de
l'armée malienne
dès le lendemain du lancement de
l'intervention militaire
laurent fabius le rappeler cet ensemble
que les vingt-sept nous ont apporté un
soutien sans réserve
la france a reçu un appui technique de
plusieurs pays notamment du royaume uni
l'allemagne qui enverra à bamako un
contingent de formateurs apporté un
soutien logistique et monsieur le
ministre des affaires étrangères je
crois avoir compris que demain se
tiendrait un conseil des ministres des
affaires étrangères européens
je pense que ce sujet sera à l'ordre du
jour il nous faut poursuivre dans cette
voie de manière pragmatique en
accentuant nos efforts de partage et de
mutualisation des équipements et des
capacités
ces enjeux sont ceux de l'europe
concrète
mes chers collègues celle de l'europe
seule de l'europe qui avance au
quotidien c'est la méthode qui a été
utilisée est pour moi c'est la bonne
nous la soutenons
merci monsieur le président
dans la suite du débat la parole est aux
orateurs des groupes
je passe la parole à monsieur christian
cambours pour le groupe ump
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre des affaires étrangères madame
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
six jours après la décision du président
de la république d'une intervention
militaire au mali
le gouvernement engage ce débat en
application de l'article 35 de la
constitution
nous souhaitons tout d'abord vous faire
part de notre satisfaction pour la mise
en oeuvre de cette disposition
constitutionnelle qui permet
l'information la plus précise des
parlementaires au moment où nos forces
armées sont engagés dans un conflit
sensible vous nous avez rappelé monsieur
le ministre
avec précisions la chronologie des faits
qui ont conduit à cette décision du
président de la république depuis des
années en effet la présence de
mouvements terroristes
c'est intimement mêlée à l'ancienne
revendications touareg pour aboutir à
une double constatation le mali a perdu
sa souveraineté sur la moitié nord de
son territoire le nord-mali est devenu
un véritable sanctuaire pour des
djihadistes cachant sous de soi disant
convictions religieuses toutes sortes de
trafics et constituant ainsi une très
lourde menace pour les pays voisins pour
la france et pour l'europe toute entière
alors que s'organisait avec difficulté
la mise en place de la force africaine
de stabilisation prévue par la
résolution 20 85 du conseil de sécurité
des nations unies les mouvements
jihadistes ont opéré une convergence et
se sont mis en mouvement afin d'empêcher
la stratégie des nations unies face au
peu de résistance opposée par les forces
armées maliennes et à l'instabilité
politique qui règne au sein du régime
malien depuis des mois le risque était
grand d'assister à l'implosion brutale
du mali tout entier est de voir
s'installer au coeur même de l'afrique
un régime terroriste menaçant l'ensemble
du sahel
une partie du continent africain et à
terme l'europe
dès lors dès lors c'est à bon droit que
le président de la république a pris la
difficile décision d'engager nos forces
armées et c'est donc sans ambiguïté que
le groupe ump apporte un soutien à cet
engagement par ses liens historiques
avec le continent africain par l'action
qu'elle mène au titre de la coopération
et du développement
la france se devait de prendre une part
prépondérante pour sauver cet état a mis
pour assurer la sécurité des 6000
français qui y résident et poursuivre la
recherche inlassable des huit otages
français qui vivent l'enfer depuis trop
longtemps
à cet instant notre pensée va d'abord
vers eux et vers leurs familles comme
nous pensons aussi avec tristesse et
consternation au sort qui a été réservé
au soldat français tué lors de l'assaut
et à denis allex l'otage
vraisemblablement assassiné lors de
l'opération de sauvetage qui a
malheureusement échoué en somalie
notre pensée va aussi vers le lieutenant
damien boiteux qui a péri au mali aux
premières heures de l'offensive en
s'opposant courageusement à la
progression des bandes armées
terroristes enfin nous voulons assurer
nos troupes françaises et leurs alliés
de notre soutien sans faille et de notre
admiration
les français doivent savoir que c'est
aussi pour leur sécurité que ces femmes
et ces hommes se battent que nos soldats
soient remerciés
si notre approbation vous est acquise
monsieur le ministre elle n'est
cependant ni aveugle ni béate
elle se veut responsable et lucide pour
avoir déjà connu l'engagement de nos
forces au liban en afghanistan en côte
d'ivoire et en libye la france est hélas
bien placé pour mesurer tous les risques
qui pèsent sur une telle opération
le devoir de la représentation nationale
à travers ce débat
et de vous inviter à ne pas tomber dans
le piège
hélas inhérents au choix courageux que
vous avez fait les risques
nous les connaissons et lentement au fil
des jours ils vont apparaître risque
d'enlisement risque d'isolement
enfin risque pour la sécurité même de
notre territoire
si rapidement une solution politique ne
vient pas se substituer aux bruits des
armes
le risque d'enlisement est bien celui
qui nous menace le plus on le constate
chaque jour avec inquiétude c'est une
guerre différentes qu'il faut livrer
c'est une guerre où la technologie la
plus sophistiquée de nos armes peut être
chaque jour mises en défaut par les
pratiques de guérilla sur un territoire
immense que maîtrise parfaitement ses
terroristes pour prendre kona ils ne
sont arrivés ni avec des chars ni même
avec des pick up mais en autobus se
mêlant d'abord à la population
puis faisant usage soudain de leurs
armes alors qu'elle livre blanc va nous
livrer les bonnes solutions
quelle arme décisive vont permettre à
nos troupes de débusquer les djihadistes
des nord désormais noyés au sein des
populations locales
et quand nous aurons reconquis ses
villes ses villages qui en assurera la
gouvernance après la faiblesse ou lady
ou l'inexistence des autorités locales
fait craindre le pire
certes il y aura la misma la force
africaine de stabilisation mais croit
ton réellement que des soldats ouest
africain imposeront leur autorité à
kidal en plein siège touareg et là le
risque est grand de voir maintenir
pendant longtemps
pendant très longtemps des forces
françaises pour empêcher le retour des
insurgés
nous n'avons pas la capacité de
maîtriser dans la durée un territoire
plus grand que la france est aussi
accidenté que l'afghanistan
chacun je le sais cela n'est ni possible
ni même souhaitable
prenons garde de ne pas nous faire
entraîner dans cette voie là le risque
d'isolement n'est pas moindre
la france ne peut pas porter seul toute
la lutte contre le terrorisme
nous n'en avons ni les moyens nous n'en
avons pas non plus la vocation la
relation de la france avec ses
partenaires africains doivent être
fondées sur le transfert aux africains
de leur propre dispositif de sécurité
on voit malheureusement aujourd'hui on
en voit les limites
aujourd'hui nous intervenons mais nous
intervenons presque seule une fois de
plus
l'union européenne vient de montrer
qu'elle n'est pas tout à fait au rendez
vous l'europe n'est pas en capacité
d'avoir une politique et des moyens
d'action commun vis-à-vis du flanc sud
du continent et nous n'avons visiblement
pas converti l'europe à l'afrique
il est vrai nous recevons de nombreux
concours logistique des moyens de
transport de troupes qui nous faut au
demeurant toujours défaut mais deux
soldats expérimentés susceptibles de
participer activement à cette opération
nous n'envoyons pas venir il faudra en
tirer les leçons d'abord pour notre
propre politique de défense
le président vient de l'aborder à un
moment où nous finalisons le livre blanc
pour l'europe
ensuite à quelques jours du 50e
anniversaire du traité d'amitié franco
allemand il nous faudra dépasser notre
déception et donner enfin une nouvelle
ambition à la coopération franco
allemand
les etats unis nous apportent leurs
encouragements et un soutien non
négligeable pour le renseignement et la
logistique
mais au regard de notre propre
engagement à leurs côtés en afghanistan
est ce bien suffisant l'algérie
l'algérie enfin va peut-être commencer à
jouer le rôle essentiel qui doit
absolument être le sien les nouvelles
d'aujourd'hui vont dans le bon sens
forte d'une armée de 400 mille hommes
elle est à la vérité la seule puissance
militaire de la région fermer ses
frontières autorisé le survol de son
territoire tout cela est utile mais on
peut s'interroger sur des attitudes
ambiguës du passé et si la presse
algérienne qui changent de ton certes
semble redouter des relents de
néocolonialisme la présence militaire
française
actuel au mali il faut que l'algérie
avec l'aide et le soutien de la france
prenne toute sa part dans la résolution
de ce conflit car c'est sa propre
stabilité qui est aussi en jeu risque
enfin d'une absence de solution
politique durable
le bruit des armes n'a qu'un temps il
faudra très vite que la france et ses
partenaires aident le mali et ses
voisins a élaboré une solution politique
durable
elle devra prendre en compte les
revendications ancien des communauté
touareg mais aussi l'aspiration des
populations maliennes à une société plus
soucieuse de lutte contre la pauvreté
que de lutte politicienne interne
si tel n'est pas le cas cela aura été
une opération militaire pour rien et
tout recommencera avec en plus une
exportation du terrorisme sur le sol
français pour se venger des échecs et
les destructions que nous faisons subir
aux jihadistes ce qui vient de se passer
aujourd'hui même dans le sud de
l'algérie est déjà un signe inquiétant
pour notre part nous ne ferons pas non
plus l'économie d'une révision de notre
politique de développement vis-à-vis du
mali et des 16 autres pays prioritaire
de la coopération française
c'est en effet sur le terreau du
sous-développement que prospèrent les
mouvements révolutionnaires qui propose
l'instauration de toutes sortes de
trafics comme seule réponse à la
pauvreté
le mali est un pays pauvres parmi les
plus pauvres de la planète au mali
l'espérance de vie moyenne est
inférieure de 20 ans à celle des pays
européens
un enfant qui n'est au mali à 50 fois
plus de risque de mourir avant de cinq
ans qu'un petit français or à ne pas
considérer l'afrique subsaharienne comme
une priorité absolue de notre aide au
développement nous et toute l'europe
nous portons quelque part une part de
responsabilité dans la baie
désagrégation de ce pays
la future loi de programmation monsieur
le ministre du développement sur le
développement devra je l'espère et nous
l'espérons procédé durablement à ce
réexamen voilà monsieur le ministre
pourquoi notre soutien total est aussi
un soutien lucide au moment où et lâche
d'autres initiatives nationales du
gouvernement ne vont peut-être pas
toutes dans le sens de l'apaisement
nous vous assurons néanmoins de notre
totale solidarité dans ce conflit parce
que au mali c'est de nos valeurs
communes
il s'agit et c'est pour la paix du monde
qu ensemble nous nous battons merci
merci la parole est à présent madame
michelle demessine pour le groupe crc
monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre des affaires
étrangères mesdames et messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs
nos premières pensées vont aux vies et
notre solidarité vont aux victimes aux
soldats disparus
le soldat boiteux aux premières heures
de l'offensive
notre solidarité nous penser aussi aux
otages et familles d'otages qui vivent
une angoisse qu on ne peut s'imaginer
depuis le vendredi 11 janvier
la france est en guerre il s'agit d'une
action grave potentiellement lourde de
conséquence décidé comme il en va de sa
responsabilité par le président de la
république
les sénateurs du groupe communiste
républicain et citoyen n'ont jamais
considéré l'entrée de leur pays dans un
conflit comme une victoire annoncée
comme une solution positive à une
situation donnée quelle qu'elle soit et
considère que le choix des armes est
toujours le résultat d'un échec échec
économique échec social ou culturel
échec diplomatique et politique
trop souvent la guerre laisse une
situation dégradée toujours l meurtri
les populations est enracinée n
ces propos ne sont pas ceux d'une
pacifiste béate ou idéaliste
ils sont le résultat de l'analyse lucide
de l'histoire ancienne ou récente où il
nous pensons toujours que la guerre
n'est pas une fatalité que la résolution
des conflits devait être le résultat
d'un travail diplomatique considérable
en amont pour négocier débattre d
amorcer l'exemple malien est édifiant
c'est le résultat d'une catastrophe
annoncée qui amenait un pays longtemps
présentée comme une réussite
démocratique africaine se déliter
son état s'est effondré la misère se
développer plus encore
faut-il rappeler que le mali est l'un
des pays les plus pauvres du monde
peut-on penser que tout a été vraiment
entrepris pour construire une
alternative une alternative à la
déferlante islamiste qui est maintenant
une réalité au mali comme dans de trop
nombreux pays la crise malienne c'est le
résultat du maintien de ce pays dans un
sous développement économique social et
institutionnel par des décennies de
domination occidentale et de sociétés
multinationales dont la préoccupation
première n'était pas en bleu c'est
l'épanouissement des populations
plus ponctuellement la crise actuelle
est la conséquence indirecte et cela
doit être rappelée de l'intervention en
libye qui a permis la dissémination d'un
arsenal considérable dans l'ensemble de
la région
cette intervention est également poussée
des touareg déjà de longue date en
rébellion contre l'état malien à revenir
sur leur terre dans les conditions de
précipitation qui ouvrait le chemin à la
déstabilisation
je le disais à l'instant l'état malien
s'est effondré la déliquescence de son
armée depuis le coup d'état de 2012 a
aussi contribué à laisser la voie libre
aux groupes islamistes et pour certains
d'entre eux terroristes
la france qui a exercé exerce encore une
forme de tutelle sur la région ne peut
s'exonérer même si elle regrette cette
situation une certaine responsabilité
dans cette terrible évolution ses
premières réflexions fait la réalité
s'impose à nous des groupes armés sous
l'influencé la plus radicale de l'islam
isme combattants certains directement
liés à al-qaïda comme aqmi occupe depuis
des mois le nord du pays faisant régner
la terreur appliquant la charia lundi
symbole de cette violence et la
destruction du patrimoine historique
constitué les mausolée soufi ce de
tombouctou
bien entendu faut faire la part des
choses
la notion de groupe terroriste ne peut
être appliquée à l'ensemble de ses
mouvements
il serait donc utile monsieur le
ministre que vous décriviez avec la
précision qui vous caractérisent
la réalité des adversaires que la france
affronte aujourd'hui qu'en est-il par
exemple de la mouvance indépendantiste
ou autonomistes touareg non liés
historiquement avec l'islamisme radical
ne doit-on pas veillé avec une grande
vigilance à ne pas faire d'amalgamé qui
pourrait servir de prétexte à des
exactions contre les populations touareg
comme ci comme ça on est déjà rendu
responsable dans le passé l'armée
malienne
cette force composite menées par des
mouvements ce incontestablement
menaçante pour les des halles de
démocratie et de progrès ont fait
mouvement jeudi vers bamako la capitale
fallait-il laisser ses forces conquérir
au delà de bamako l'ensemble du mali la
réponse est clairement non
il fallait empêcher dans l'urgence
l'avancé de ces groupes dont l'idéologie
porte à instaurer des régimes
despotiques d'une rare violence en
particulier à l'égard des femmes
j'insiste également sur le fait que ces
groupes s'appuient souvent sur une
organisation de type mafieuse leur
assurant un financement important issus
du trafic de drogue ou des armes
le sahel est ainsi devenue une
gigantesque plaque tournante
nous approuvons donc cette décision
d'éviter la prise de bamako et
d'empêcher l'avancée des troupes
islamistes de plus cette action de la
france résultent d'une demande
officielle l'intervention du président
malien au titre de l'article 51 de la
charte des nations unies
elle reçoit d'évidence le soutien des
populations au mali des maliens de
france et de leurs organisations
elle reçoit aujourd'hui une approbation
sans ambiguïté de l'ensemble du conseil
de sécurité de l'onu fut au delà des
premiers résultats de cette intervention
se pose immédiatement la question de la
suite j'ai lu hier que des responsables
américains redoutent est un enlisement
rapide comme en afghanistan
que se passera-t-il si les djihadistes
trouve reçu refuge dans les montagnes de
l'ouest
'l'annonce d'un engagement militaire de
notre
pays par le président de la république
jusqu'à la stabilisation du mali nous
semble une échéance bien lointaine qui
donne un cadre trop large et trop floue
à notre intervention
nous souhaitons donc que ce débat puisse
notamment apporter des précisions à ce
sujet prenons garde que nom de la lutte
contre le terrorisme
d'obédience islamisme cette guerre qui
risque d'être longue qui risque d'être
longue
nous nous rappelle fâcheusement le
concept de guerre de civilisation porté
par george bush en 2001 il faut
travailler isoler les groupes à
proprement parler terroristes qui sont
minoritaires en évidence je le répète
tout amalgame avec des forces moins
radicale qui se sont engagés dans ce
conflit
du fait de la déstabilisation du pays et
de la région
nous soutenons clairement que soit
proclamée l'objectif de reconstruire de
reconstruction de l'état malien et de
restauration de la démocratie
adopter uniquement la posture d'une
déclaration de guerre à l'islamisme
radical est autorisé et au terrorisme
serait dangereux et vingt six actions
politiques diplomatiques contre l'islam
radical
véritable fascisme de notre temps il y a
il y à cet axe cette action doit être
cohérente qui financent certains groupes
en actions au mali si ce n'est le qatar
doit-on se voiler la face les gros bras
radicaux à l'oeuvre en libye en syrie
comme au soudan - palestine soutiennent
ou vont soutenir activement les forces
que nous commençons à combattre au mali
que fait notre diplomatie à l'égard des
émirats où le président de la république
vient de se rendre à l'égard du qatar ou
de live de l'arabie saoudite régime
monarchique et despotique qui fondent
leur influence sur leurs immenses
richesses pour les dissuader de
continuer leur action proche ou moyen
orient comme en afrique pour
déstabiliser divisé et finalement
combattre les valeurs démocratiques
les valeurs de progrès d'épanouissement
monsieur le ministre lorsque les
autorités où habite décide en arabie
saoudite de fer décapité au sabre une
employé sri lankaise immigrés ne
voit-elle pas des signaux de haine et de
violence qui se propage dans le monde
entier et au mali nous demandons donc
avec force une nouvelle cohérence dans
notre politique à l'égard d'un de
l'islam radical
enfin demandons que conformément aux
engagements internationaux
cette intervention soit pris en charge
par un nombre croissant de pays au
premier rang desquels les pays africains
la force d'intervention décidé par les
nations unies par la résolution de 1095
doit devenir réalité au plus vite
il faut à tout prix éviter que nous
restions un temps indéterminé seul en
première ligne
nous avons pris nos responsabilités et
il fallait le faire mais ce cavalier
seul ne peut durer c'est notre autorité
politique et démocratique qui est en jeu
ainsi que notre sécurité se confie ce
conflit le drame malien peut-être aussi
un signal de plus à l'urgence du
développement
l'afrique possède toutes les richesses
naturelles et humaines pour se
développer il faut pour cela à cesser le
pillage des matières premières et des
compétences intellectuelles
ces mots que beaucoup ici ont utilisés
doivent enfin devenir des actes afin que
l'afrique note qu'on ne compte pas un
mali puis deux puis trois avant
l'embrasement de toute une région
merci de votre attention
merci je passe la parole au président
françois zocchetto pour le groupe
udi us et monsieur le président monsieur
ministre des affaires étrangères
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues
la puissance est une donnée relative
toutefois elle n'est pas sans entraîner
certains de voir aussi je ne crois pas
me tromper en affirmant que chaque fois
que la france mais son appareil de
défense et le courage de ces soldats au
profit de la défense de la liberté notre
pays sonore et respecte ainsi sa mission
historique parmi les nations je
souhaiterais à mon tour ou non des
sénateurs du groupe u10 uc joindre notre
voix à l'hommage rendu au lieutenant
damien boiteux qui a perdu la vie
pendant les premières heures du conflit
nos soldats reviennent progressivement
d'une opération difficile en afghanistan
longue de dix années est lourde de
dizaines de perte d' homme irremplaçable
le lieutenant boiteux vient ainsi
rejoindre la liste de nos concitoyens
disparus dans le combat que la france a
toujours mené pour la liberté
le mali est depuis son indépendance
un ami indéfectible de la france nous
comptons plus de cent mille
ressortissants maliens sur notre
territoire et combien d'autres citoyens
français restent attachés par leur
famille ou leurs amis au mali le mali
s'est également imposé depuis de
nombreuses années comme une terre
d'accueil d'un nombre important de nos
concitoyens installé à bamako ou
ailleurs forte de ses liens profondément
enraciné la france ne pouvait que
répondre vigoureusement à l'appel lancé
par le président malien pour défendre
son territoire et défendre ces
institutions menacée en effet la crise
catastrophique que traverse le nord du
mali depuis près d'un an est une plaie
béante au coeur du sahel
la conjugaison des forces des rebelles
touareg revenus des rangs de l'armée de
kadhafi avec les groupes islamistes qui
alimente tous les trafics entre la
mauritanie l'algérie le niger et même
d'autres pays
cette conjugaison a eu raison de la
stabilité et de la paix qui ont
caractérisé pendant de longues années le
mali en réalité nous connaissons assez
mal notre ennemi dans ce dossier les
rebelles nordistes sont un bataillon
hétéroclite qui comporte aussi bien des
touareg laïque que des terroristes
islamistes des criminels et des pillards
en tout genre il ya une seule certitude
désormais toutefois ces cas tombouctou
cité universitaire millénaire élevé au
rang du patrimoine mondial de l'humanité
a tombouctou on coupe désormais depuis
plusieurs mois on coupe des mains on
excise on viole on pille et on tue
impunément des exactions sans nom sont
perpétrés sur un territoire plus vaste
que celui de la france
des villes entières sont désormais
réglés sous la coupe de la charia et
d'organisations criminelles qui font
peser un risque généralisé sur la
stabilité de tous les états voisins du
mali bien sûr mais aussi sur la sécurité
même de la france et de l'europe
car ne nous y trompons pas le nord du
mali est situé à moins de trois heures
d'avion du sud de la france
nous n'imaginons pas ce que deviendrait
la france si elle devenait la cible d'un
sanctuaire terroriste
nous ne pouvons pas laisser un nouvel
afghanistan apparaître au coeur de
l'afrique
ces groupes financés à la fois par
l'argent des trafics de stupéfiants par
l'immigration id illégale par le
rançonnage le rap le pillage alimente
une source de haine contre notre pays
contre tout ce qui ressemble de près ou
de loin à l'expression de la liberté
aussi monsieur le ministre les sénateurs
du groupe udc ne peuvent que saluer la
réponse du président de la république à
l'appel lancé par le mas
le 16 janvier ce 16 janvier est
malheureusement un jour anniversaire
en effet le 16 janvier 2011 avait lieu
la première incursion des terroristes
avec la prise de ménaka et dès le 26
janvier 2012 notre groupe
par la voix de joël guerriau lors d'une
séance de questions d'actualité
alerté le gouvernement ait suggéré une
intervention rapide de nos forces armées
peu de temps après tombaient les places
militaire de tombouctou de gao et de
kidal
le problème n'est donc pas nouveau
aujourd'hui 12 mois ont passé
aujourd'hui sur un plan purement
tactique ses six premiers jours
d'intervention semble positif
ce succès opérationnel n'est pourtant
pas ce sens un certain nombre
d'incertitudes
de nombreuses questions demandent des
réponses et justifie la procédure de
l'article 35 de la constitution
monsieur le ministre vous avez évoqué
une intervention rapide de l'ordre de
quelques semaines qu'est ma première
question est ne risquons nous pas de
nous enliser dans un engagement intensif
est exigeant en homme comme en matériel
sans un appui significatif de nos alliés
en effet la france est la seule
puissance à avoir répondu à l'appel du
mali en dépit du mandat confié aux
forces internationales dans le cadre de
la résolution 2085 du conseil de
sécurité la france est bien la seule
puissance militaire à ce jour engagé
dans le déroulement opérationnelle du
conflit malien alors les forces de la
cedeao tarder à se rassembler et quand
bien même on parle seulement de 2900
sommes ici deux bataillons d'armes est
différente pour couvrir au sol un
territoire je le rappelle qui est plus
vaste que celui de la france
plus grave encore les troupes maliennes
sont désorganisés mal équipés et parfois
même j'irai jusqu'à dire tenter pour
certaines de rejoindre les rangs
nordistes
nous avons bien compris donc que l'issue
militaire du conflit reste incertaine
tant que la france ne parviendra pas à
réunir une coalition la plus large
possible
certes l'algérie nous a ouvert son
espace aérien
certes les états unis le royaume uni le
canada ont donné des signes de soutien
immédiat mais comment ne pas regretter
l'absence de concertation visible et de
réaction de l'europe ce ne sont pas les
quelques commentaires du président de la
commission européenne qui peuvent
masquer l'incapacité de l'europe à
réagir diplomatiquement et militairement
nous demandons une réunion des chefs
d'état et de gouvernement de l'union
européenne
monsieur le ministre car nous souhaitons
une réaction à la mesure de l'enjeu pour
l'europe
la deuxième interrogation porte bien sûr
sur le sort des otages cela a déjà été
évoqué leur sécurité n'est-elle pas mise
en cause par l'intervention au mali de
quelles informations disposons nous
pouvons nous espérer leur libération
là encore bien sûr de nombreuses
questions méritent d'être éclaircies
sous respect nous comprenons bien du
respect dû à la discrétion demandée par
ce genre de sujet enfin quelles sont les
perspectives de trouver une solution
politique à ce conflit
notre intervention est elle seulement
limité à bloquer la progression des
terroristes ou s'agit-il d'appuyer la
restauration de la souveraineté du mali
sur toute la région du nord donc sur
tout l'intégrité de son territoire et
cette entreprise de restauration de
souveraineté sera exclusivement menée
par l'emploi de la force ou existe-t-il
encore une chance pour le dialogue
diplomatique
monsieur le ministre en dépit des
quelques interrogations importantes que
vous ne manquerez pas d'éclaircir je
tiens en conclusion au nom de l'ensemble
du groupe u10 uc a rappelé notre soutien
ferme et indéfectible à nos troupes qui
sont engagées sur le terrain
nous leur transmettons tous nos voeux de
succès et nous nous en remettons à vous
pour garantir la sécurité des otages
comme de nos soldats
je vous remercie merci merci la parole
est à présent monsieur jean pierre
chevènement pour le groupe
rds
on
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre des affaires étrangères
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues le coup d'arrêt donné
par l'armée française à la progression
vers bamako de colonne islamistes sur
ordre du président de la république à
l'appel des autorités légitimes du mali
était nécessaire
le groupe du rdse approuve donc la
décision prise sous empire de l'urgence
par le chef de l'état il ne s'agit pas
d'une ingérence
comme je les ai entendus dire qu'ils
auraient violé la souveraineté d'un pays
africain indépendant
au contraire il s'agit d'une assistance
apportée un pays ami en grand danger
dont l'intégrité territoriale avait été
violée par des groupes terroristes
entendant imposer leur loi et quelle loi
et dont non seulement la souveraineté
mais la survie même été compromise si
des éléments islamistes armés avaient pu
continuer leur raid vers le sud
l'intervention de la france c'est fait
en vertu de l'article 51 de la charte
des nations unies
elle a donné lieu la réunion du conseil
de sécurité qui a confirmé la légitimité
de l'intervention française
certes la guerre est toujours haïssable
mais il est des guerres inévitable celle
là l'est car elle répond à un souci de
légitime défense
non seulement de la part du mali mais
aussi des pays d'afrique sahélienne y
compris l'algérie d'ailleurs et des pays
européens clairement visés comme le
nôtre par les menaces d'aqmi
certes une solution politique partiel
avec des groupes projetant le terrorisme
hu était préférable pour isoler les
groupes terroristes et rétablir à
moindre frais l'intégrité territoriale
du mali ce qui implique un modus vivendi
durable
entre les populations du nord et du sud
de ce pays
une telle perspective n'aurait pas
dispensés en tout état de cause de
réduire les éléments terroristes dans
leur repaire du nord-mali mais le choix
d'ansar al din groupe touareg
fondamentalistes et de son chef
iyad ag ghaly d'euros de rompre toute
négociation avec le m lna et de se
joindre au groupe terroriste que son
aqmi et le mot zhao pour menacer bamako
et mettre bas la république et l'état du
mali ont rendu caduque
une telle perspective il n'était tout
simplement pas possible de laisser se
constituer sur les décombres de la
république malienne un sanctuaire du
terrorisme au coeur de l'afrique
la réactivité exceptionnelle des forces
armées françaises de tête saluer et
hommages rendus à nos soldats tombés
dans l'accomplissement de leur devoir au
service de la france
on mesure à l'occasion de ces événements
l'intérêt des forces françaises
prépositionnées et soit dit en passant
l'erreur d'appréciation que je vais
signalé lors de l'habitat de l'adoption
de livres blancs qui consistait à ne
vouloir conserver qu'une seule base en
afrique de l'ouest
heureusement il restait encore quelques
forces disponibles à dakar
n'djamena et en côte d'ivoire bienvenue
et l'arrivée de matériel le rcsa gay et
hélicoptères tigre assurant une
meilleure protection à nos soldats que
les hélicoptères gazelle
un mot d'abord sur les buts politique de
l'intervention
le président à blick on a défini trois
arrêtés agression terroriste sécurisé
bamako permettre enfin au mali de
recouvrer son intégrité territoriale
la france at il ajouté n'a pas vocation
à rester aux manies son but est de
préparer la venue une force africaine
encadrés et soutenus par la communauté
internationale afin qu'il y ait au mali
des autorités légitimes un processus
électoral
et plus de terroristes quand nous
partirons constatons cependant que pour
le moment la france se trouve seul en
ligne avec ce qui reste des forces
armées maliennes combattante
c'est une réalité et s'élancer m'en
mords que se révèlent la réalité sur la
base de laquelle les politiques doivent
être construits
les troupes de la cedeao mettront un
certain temps pour monter en ligne
cela dépendra beaucoup des moyens
logistiques disponibles ou mis à
disposition par nos alliés une partie de
ces forces sera peu opérationnels ses
forces dans leur majorité seront plus
des forces de maintien de la paix que
des forces d'intervention proprement dit
on peut espérer que certains pays comme
le tchad le niger ou la mauritanie
pourront fournir d'efforts ça guérit
sans être aux abonnés absents nos
partenaires européens manifestent peu
d'empressement à se joindre à nous c'est
à l'aune des réalités là encore qu'on
mesurera la pertinence des discours sur
la défense européenne
espérons que le conseiller misère
étrangères européens qui devraient se
réunir demain monsieur ministre
démentira le constat fait par amante de
gouvernement d'une mobilisation je cite
un peu minimale de l'union européenne et
de certaines absences regrettable je
suis moins surpris que d'autres de cette
carence ainsi l'acquisition du troisième
objectif fixé par le président de la
république risque de prendre du temps
il faut en être conscient or la france
est engagée
il vaut donc mieux frapper vite et fort
pour dérouter l'adversaire et profiter
autant que faire se peut de l'effet de
surprise ne nous laissons pas enliser
dans le schéma peu opérationnels selon
moi initialement prévu si les alliances
doivent avoir un sens c'est maintenant
elles doivent se manifester en tout état
de cause il faut acheminer des renforts
il ne faut pas attendre trop longtemps
pour occuper les villes du nord
une précaution indispensable mais vous
l'avez rappelé dissocier autant que
possible les populations du nord touareg
et autres des éléments terroristes ont
en tout état de cause ne pas les
solidariser éviter au maximum ce qu'on
appelle les dégâts et dommages
collatéraux ne sous-estimons pas non
plus dimension ethnique du conflit il y
a un problème touareg au mali qui ne se
posent pas d'hier puisque nous en sommes
à la quatrième rébellion touareg
depuis l'indépendance en 1960 les
autorités de bamako doivent être
fortement incités à trouver un accord
avec le m lna et avec les éléments
égarés d'ansar al din qui réprouvent le
terrorisme et souhaitent le rejoindre
l'objectif est la refondation
démocratique du mali
celle ci sera d'autant plus facile que
le rapport des forces aura évolué au
détriment des groupes terroristes
une certaine autonomie territoriale des
provinces du nord serait alors
souhaitable
je me félicite que la déclaration
gouvernementale est évoqué ce problème
et le souci de le voir abordés dans la
feuille de route que va adopter le
gouvernement malien
c'est le coeur des populations qui doit
s'exprimer en faveur d'une telle
refondation démocratique au nord comme
au sud
nul ne peut ignorer que la répression
des précédentes rébellion n'a pas laissé
de bons souvenirs aux populations du
nord les ressentiments existants
n'excuse d'ailleurs en aucune manière le
massacre récent et sauvage de soldats
maliens
le problème touareg n'est pas propre au
mali les touareg environ un million de
personnes sont dispensés en trop au
moins six états le mali le niger le
burkina faso le nigeria l'algérie la
libye ils sont mêlés à d'autres ethnies
arabe berabiches ou chambi noir sprinter
peu le bambara etc etc je doute pour ma
part que les villes du nord puisse être
reprise sans l'appoint substantielle de
militaires français
c'est le doute que j'exprime le problème
de fond c'est plus que le coup d'arrêt
et le billet de retour de nos soldats
c'est le temps le temps dans ces espaces
immenses qui vont de l'atlantique à la
mer rouge
battus non seulement par les vents de
sable mais aussi par les vents de
contestation venus du fond de l'histoire
fondamentalistes et autres bien avant la
colonisation les frontières contre assez
il y à peine un siècle
nos officiers n'ont pas encore été
pleinement intériorisée par ces
populations
même si la loi internationale celle de
l'onu est celle de l'union africaine
leur confère à juste titre un caractère
d'intangibilité les tribus touareg par
exemple se connaissent et
s'interpénètrent par delà les frontières
quoi qu'il en soit la communauté
internationale devra financer et mettre
en oeuvre un vaste plan de développement
du sahel
l'union européenne pourrait montrer dans
cette affaire son utilité pour mettre
avec nous le temps nous avons dans cette
région du monde un allié
il faut le dire parce que cela n'a pas
été dit suffisamment c'est l'algérie
c'est le seul grand état de la région
sahélienne
je vais à part le maroc située plus à
l'ouest les autres états sont fragiles y
compris le nigeria
rongé par un mouvement djihadiste le
boko haram
on ne peut pas concevoir la paix la
stabilité de cette immense région sans
l'algérie dont l'armée soit dit en
passant dépasse 300 mille hommes
l'algérie elle même dû faire face dans
les années 1990 à la terreur islamiste
et l'a payé un lourd tribut au
djihadisme plus de cent cinquante mille
morts en ce moment même ses soldats
doivent faire face à in aménas ce à une
tentative d'enlèvement concernant des
ressortissants français japonais mais
aussi britanniques et norvégiens
j'entends s'exprimer ici et là des
réserves des critiques les terroristes
auraient pu s'approvisionner en essence
en algérie pour quiconque connaît le
terrain
chacun sait que il est très difficile de
contrôler les trafics d'essence 1 sur
toutes les frontières de l'algérie du
maroc à la tunisie
voilà
la réalité aussi bien l'algérie qui
privilégié la voie d'un isolement des
groupes terroristes a choisi clairement
de leur fermer sa frontière longue de
200 kilomètres avec le mali l'algérie
autorisé le survol de son territoire par
les avions français
bref dans la lutte contre le terrorisme
l'algérie et la france combattent côte à
côte au moment où le président de la
république françois hollande vient de
déclarer à alger le 20 décembre 2012
devant les deux chambres du parlement
algérien vouloir ouvrir une nouvelle
page dans les relations entre la france
et l'algérie
il ne faudrait pas que ceux qui sont pas
encore tout à fait résolus à tourner la
page en pêche par myopie la construction
au sahel avec tous les pays riverains
d'un espace pacifique et stable
durablement purger du terrorisme
celui-ci n'apporterait que mahler à la
population de ces régions
nous comptons monsieur le ministre des
affaires étrangères sur le gouvernement
de jean marc ayrault
sous l'autorité du président de la
république pour bâtir un avenir partagé
entre la france l'algérie et les pays
africains amis
cette vision politique est nécessaire
pour résoudre les immenses problèmes qui
se posent aujourd'hui à cette région à
commencer par celui de sa sécurité
nous faisons confiance au gouvernement
et à vous-même particulièrement monsieur
militaire étrangère pour mettre en
oeuvre les médiations nécessaire tisser
les alliances coordonner l'effort
certes c'est une tâche gigantesque mais
le soutien du pays tout entier nous fera
pas défaut
6 d'efforts lui est convenablement
expliqué dans toutes ses dimensions
comme non nous n'en doutons pas vous
concernant et comme nous y encourageons
d'ailleurs l'ensemble du gouvernement
merci merci la parole est un monsieur
joël labbé pour le groupe écologiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre des affaires étrangères madame
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues j'interviens aujourd'hui
en tant que parlementaire écologiste
mais également en tant que président
délégué au groupe d'amitié france mali
de notre assemblée et j'interviens aussi
parce que je le suis
en tant que membre nous du mouvement des
citoyens du monde la france intervient
militairement mali en soutien aux forces
armées maliennes à la demande du
président malien par intérim
si le recours aux interventions
militaires n'est évidemment jamais
souhaitable
il peut s'avérer nécessaire et
l'offensive sur la ville de cosne à qui
a eu lieu en début du mois et le risque
de voir ces groupes armés déstabiliser
davantage le pays avec les conséquences
que l'on imagine pour les populations
civiles
et cela sur l'ensemble des pays de
l'afrique de l'ouest nous nous
conduisent à approuver et à soutenir le
choix du président de la république
française la crise malienne est la
résultante d'une déstabilisation a crû
de toute la bande sahélienne que le
conflit libyen a encore accentué en
effet celui ci a déjà permis à des
groupes djihadistes de s'armer
dangereusement
2faites l'intervention militaire en
libye n'a pas été suivi d'une véritable
politique tant française qu européenne
de développement suffisant en direction
des pays de la région notamment le mali
et le niger
et nous en subissons les conséquences
aujourd'hui
il est primordial d'en tirer les leçons
nous ne créerons jamais les conditions
de l'avènement d'un état de droit par la
seule intervention militaire
je cite ici notre collègue daniel cohn
bendit qui lorsqu'il a cité hier au
parlement européen la population au nord
mali vie dans un extrême dénuement
cela évidemment favorise notamment les
trafics tels ceux des armes et des
drogues et les liens entre pauvreté
défaut d'éducation
et terrorisme sont malheureusement bien
connu par conséquent la mise en place
d'une politique de développement sur le
long terme et urgente
c'est là la vraie question au delà de
l'opération militaire maintenant cours
et dans l'urgence par sept la question
est de tirer les leçons de l'échec du
soutien du simple soutien à un état de
droit au mali et du manque d'une
véritable politique de développement
notre coopération avec le mali doit
s'inscrire sur le long terme et reposer
sur des valeurs d'éthique de respect de
nos partenaires c'est particulièrement
important de lauréats de le réaffirmer
dans la mesure où le mali est classée au
170e rang sur l'échelle de la pauvreté
alors que son sol est riche en matières
premières et que la tentation de
certains est grande de s'accaparer ses
richesses
l'uranium de cette région pour ne
prendre qu'un seul exemple attise les
convoitises
on le sait ces exploitations ne profite
quasiment pas aux populations locales
le département du morbihan une relation
privilégiée à la avec l'ensemble de la
région de kidal et nous avons reçu une
délégation de nouveaux élus delà de la
nouvelle génération de toute la région
de kidal dans le cadre de la
décentration de la décentralisation
voulue par le gouvernement malien de
l'époque c'était pas le diable c'était
y'a pas longtemps
c'était il ya deux ans et nos
interlocuteurs notamment un ancien
président de l'assemblée régionale de
kidal qui nous a quittés accents dit
accidentellement
abdou salam ag assalat nous disaient
leur volonté en tant que touareg de
s'autodéterminer se reconnaître malien
mais avoir une certaine une certaine
autonomie et à l'époque il nous mettait
en garde contre le risque de mouvements
terroristes
à un moment il m'avait expliqué son
opposition un projet d'achat par une
société australienne de terre afin
d'exploiter une mine d'uranium dans la
région très proche de kidal et il leur
avait répondu que la terre des ancêtres
n'étaient pas à vendre et que le
minéraux le mille
le plus précieux des minerais et est la
ressource en eau il m'a alors dit un
proverbe de touareg qui prend ici tout
son sens tu peux dire ce que tu veux à
celui qui a soif ils ne te demandera
toujours que de l'eau il est temps comme
a commencé à le faire notre ministre
pascal canfin délégué chargé du
développement de revoir sous votre
autorité monsieur le ministre des
affaires étrangères de revoir toute
l'architecturé des aides de la france
aux pays qui en ont besoin et notamment
ceux du sahel et la future loi
d'orientation et de programmation sur le
développement devra tracer les lignes de
nouvelles relations avec les pays les
plus pauvres
je voudrais aussi ici parler au nom de
ma collègue kalliopi yango et la
sénatrice représentant les français
établis hors de france
membre de la commission des affaires
étrangères qui a réussi qui a résidé
plus de 25 en afrique subsaharienne et
elle tenait à ce que soit précisé
d'hiver ce point vision que je partage
évidemment il me semble effectivement
important que l'accent soit mis sur la
nécessaire reconstruction de la paix et
sur le fait que l'aide au développement
devrait alors également prendre la forme
d'un accompagnement de sortie de conflit
ayant pour objectif le bien être pacifié
de tous les peuples et société vivante
au mali notamment les touareg mais aussi
les morts l'epl laissons gaillot les
bozos dans le respect des identités de
chacun
c'est dans ce cadre que devra s'inscrire
une paix durable s'il est fondamental
que les actions menées sur le territoire
malien
soit sous protection des forces
africaines la gestion du post conflit
devra elle aussi impliquer l'ensemble
des différents acteurs du développement
en conclusion il est nécessaire
d'intervenir dans l'urgence il nous sera
nécessaire ensuite de permettre les
conditions de mise en place d'un régime
politique démocratique fort et stable et
au mali et ce sera encore possible
devraient ensuite pour une véritable
politique de développement avec les axes
essentiels que sont l'alimentation le
droit à l'eau à la santé à l'éducation
nous en avons le terreau sur le sur le
territoire malien et sur le territoire
français étant donné la richesse du
réseau relationnel entre les
l'activité locale les assurances les
associations françaises et le terrain et
les connectivités malienne enfin je
voudrais citer kofi annan qui nous
disent aussi en conclusion il n'ya pas
de développement sans sécurité et de
sécurité sans développement et il ne
peut y avoir ni sécurité ni
développement si les droits de l'homme
ne sont pas respectés
je vous remercie merci la parole à
monsieur jean françois husson pour la
délégation des non inscrits
monsieur le monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre des affaires
étrangères mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues j'ai
souhaité intervenir dans ce débat et
dans le temps très court qui met un
parti pour apporter d'emblée et en toute
responsabilité
mon entier soutien à l'initiative prise
par la france au mali
je salue cette intervention parce
qu'elle s'est produite juste à temps
pour que ce pays soit en mesure de
résister résister contre le processus de
conquête du sud et il faut le dire
clairement contre les poussées
terroristes en vue de la prise du
pouvoir central et le risque
d'instauration d'une république
islamique
je reconnais sa légimité légitimité
renforcée
s'agissant du mali avec lequel la france
entretient des relations étroites pour
des raisons historiques culturels et
communautaires au regard de l'importance
de la diaspora malienne sur notre
territoire
cette légitimité est aussi d'ordre
géostratégique dans la mesure où la
france et ne l'oublions pas un
partenaire majeur et historique du mali
dont la position revêt sur le continent
africain
une importance une importance toute
particulière le soutien que j'exprime
vient aussi de ce que l'intervention de
nos militaires dont nous devons saluer
l'engagement et le courage à s'exposer
pour défendre les valeurs qui sont les
nôtres sur ce nouveau théâtre
d'opérations cette intervention s'est
faite dans le respect des cadres
juridiques et politiques
en effet c'est le présent par intérim de
la république malienne le professeur
traoré qui a sollicité notre
intervention militaire pour stopper
l'avancée des jihadistes par ailleurs
notre intervention est conforté par sa
légitimité internationale
dès lors qu'elle intervient dans le
cadre de la résolution
85 de l'onu et dans le respect des
termes de notre constitution
si comme vous le voyez monsieur le
ministre
mon soutien et sans ambiguïté je me
permets de penser que l'urgence de notre
engagement militaire au mali doit aussi
nous pousse à réfléchir à deux faits
importants peut-être premiers faits
aurions nous pu sous-estimer les forces
les moyens et les capacités de lutte de
ces groupes armés et peut-être également
avons pu ne pas vouloir croire à leur
faculté de jouer en dépit de leurs
nombreuses divergences une certaine
forme de jeu de l'union de ceux de la
solidarité puisque ces trois groupes
aqmi le mou zhao et en sarre et dean se
sont battus tous ensemble pour repousser
au sud la ligne de front et conquérir
sévaré il me semble monsieur le ministre
que cela doit inciter la france à la
plus haute vigilance dans sas certain
nombre de régions du monde où les
terrorisme rampant aux actifs masqué ou
dévoilés sont capables de s'unir pour le
pire en vue de déstabiliser les régimes
démocratiques et risquait d'ouvrir la
voie à l'ismaily à l'islamisation
politique
il m'apparaît ensuite et enfin monsieur
le ministre que nous devrons être
attentifs aux risques de renforcement ou
de radicalisation des mouvements
terroristes à l'oeuvre au mali en
réaction à notre intervention est à
l'aléa inhérent à toute intervention
militaire de l'enlisement
pour l'éviter il conviendra à me
semble-t-il qu'outre son indispensable
l'intervention militaire la france fasse
tout ce qui est en son pouvoir pour
favoriser sans ingérence
la résolution du problème politique
malien et celui des institutions de ce
pays
elle pourra je dirais même elle devrait
le faire avec l'assentiment et le
soutien de nos partenaires européens
si la parole est au président françois
rebsamen pour le groupe socialiste
ce le président sur le ministre des
affaires étrangères mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues depuis
le 11 janvier dernier sur décision du
président de la république à la demande
du président du mali
monsieur traoré et dans le respect de la
charte des nations unies la france s'est
engagée pour appuyer l'armée malienne
face à l'agression terroriste en cet
instant je tiens également à rendre
hommage à la mémoire du lieutenant
daniel boiteux tué le premier jour des
combats ainsi qu'à celle des soldats
tombés samedi dans l'opération de
somalie au nom des sénateurs socialistes
et plus largement j'en suis certain au
nom de tous mes collègues
j'exprime à leur famille à leurs proches
à leurs compagnons d'armes
mes plus sincères condoléances
je voudrais aussi saluer nos soldats
aujourd'hui engagé aux côtés des forces
maliennes 800 sont déployées sur le sol
malien et je vous écoutez monsieur le
ministre ce chiffre devrait
progressivement passé à 2500 voire de
1900 selon les dernières informations du
ministre de la défense je voudrais dire
ici que la nation a semblé admire leur
courage et leur apporte tout son soutien
mesdames messieurs mes chers collègues
que se serait-il passé si la france
n'était pas intervenue les forces
terroristes auraient continué leur
avance et faisant sauter sans difficulté
le verrou de kaunas était déjà fait et
mopti ouvrant la porte à la prise de
bamako qui serait tombée entre leurs
mains mais tant la population malienne
et nos ressortissants français à leur
merci le mali serait aujourd'hui un pays
d'otages pris lui-même en otage
pour servir de bases terroristes au
coeur du continent africain
constituant sûrement une sorte de
nouvelle arganese temps aux portes de la
méditerranée et de l'europe mais
menaçant de déstabiliser l'ensemble des
pays d'afrique de l'ouest
dès l'appel on peut le dire l'appel de
détresse du président malien
la france par la voix de son président a
su répondre présent sans tergiversation
avec sang-froid calme et détermination
le chef de l'état a fait preuve de sa
capacité de décision et d'action en
engageant nos forces armées pour aider
le peuple malien et combattre les
terroristes
les sénateurs socialistes saluent et
bien sûr personne n'en doutait
soutiennent cette décision c'est
toujours vous le savez un choix terrible
que d'engager nos soldats dans la
bataille
ce choix le président de la république
l'a fait en prenant ses responsabilités
en conscience et avec rapidité
notre pays peut en être fier et honoré
de l'avoir fait comme il l'a fait dans
le passé que ce soit en afghanistan ou
en libye
quand il s'agit d'aider des peuples à
combattre la tyrannie et la dictature
pour faire à terme nous le savons en
tous les cas nous le voulons triompher
la démocratie
à ce jour d'ores et déjà j'ai d'ores et
déjà un coup d'arrêt a été porté à
l'avancé des terroristes et nous troupe
poursuivent actuellement leur offensive
avec un déploiement nos forces
terrestres vers le nord vers le front du
nord pour y pourchasser les groupes
armés d'aqmi liés à al qaïda monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voudrais
souligner aujourd'hui devant vous
l'exemplarité qui préside à cette
intervention armée au mali exemplarité
d'abord sur la forme et le respect des
procédures
la france mes chers collègues a agi dans
le respect de la légalité internationale
conformément à la résolution 2085 adopté
le 20 décembre dernier elle a reçu le 14
janvier le soutien unanime du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu l'action déterminée de
la france salué par l'ensemble des pays
africains à accélérer accélérer leur
mobilisation et celle de la cedeao qui
traînait quelque peu qu'il faut bien le
reconnaître togo nigeria niger burkina
faso bénin sénégal
l'ine ghana le tchad ont aujourd'hui
confirmé leur participation la
participation de leurs soldats je
n'oublie pas la position très importante
de soutien de l'algérie nous en mesurons
l'importance je sais monsieur le
ministre des affaires étrangères le rôle
essentiel que vous avez joué pour
fédérer mobiliser ses participations
indispensable et je voudrais ici saluer
votre action au mali le peuple a dit son
soutien et sa reconnaissance au
président hollande et à la france sur
les chaînes de télévision et les radios
du monde entier au niveau européen dès
le déclenchement de l'offensive
française
les contacts ont été pris par le
président de la république par le
président par le ministre de la défense
et par vous même avec nos partenaires
pour les informer et les associer à
l'intervention à ceux qui déplorent la
solitude je cite du président de la
république en europe dans ce conflit
je rappelle qu'au fil des jours l'aide
apportée par les vingt-sept se met en
place
d'ores et déjà britanniques danois
belgique allemagne italie apporte un
précieux et indispensable soutien
logistique la convocation que vous avez
demandé et obtenu monsieur nice des
affaires étrangères d'un conseil
extraordinaire des affaires étrangères
de l'union européenne qui se tiendra
jeudi devrait doit permette d'accélérer
la coopération européenne il
compris militaires à l'intervention
française c'est bien le moins que nous
attendons de l'union européenne les
américains aussi ont manifesté
immédiatement leur soutien en matière de
logistique et de renseignement
les émirats enfin ont proposé à françois
hollande lors de son déplacement leur
aide matérielle financière et militaire
et puis sur notre territoire je voudrais
le dire
là encore l'information des citoyens et
celle de ses élus représentants du
peuple a été exemplaire
dès sa prise de décision le président de
la république s'est adressé aux français
pour leur en expliquer et il faudra
encore le faire les raisons et les
enjeux après le premier conseil de
défense
il est également intervenu sur les
médias pour faire le point de la
situation
relayé par des points de presse
réguliers fait par vous monsieur le
ministre et par jean yves le drian le
ministre de la défense
la représentation nationale a été
scrupuleusement tenues informées par le
premier ministre par téléphone d'abord
dès vendredi après midi le jour même du
déclenchement de l'opération
puis lors d'une réunion des responsables
parlementaires à matignon lundi soir ont
suivi les auditions des ministres par
les commissions de l'assemblée et du
sénat compétentes et aujourd'hui ce
débat qui nous réunit autour de vous
dans cet hémicycle et qui dans le même
temps réuni les députés autour du
premier ministre devrait va nous
permettre d'apporter et d'avoir toutes
les informations et les précisions
nécessaires aux questions les élus de la
nation
voilà pour la forme pour le fonds à cet
instant beaucoup de choses bien sûr ont
été dites mais je voudrais rappeler que
bien avant son élection françois
hollande avait suivi de près l'évolution
de la situation au mali et que dès son
investiture
lors de son déplacement aux états unis
il en avait alerté les autorités
américaines le travail diplomatique
et celui de nos services de
renseignement s'est poursuivie tout au
long des six derniers mois
la décision d'intervenir au mali a donc
été mûri et prise ensuite de façon
extrêmement rationnelle en fonction de
renseignements concordants sur la
dégradation accélérée de la situation et
le retard
on peut le dire pris dans la mise en
place de la misma quelle était la
situation vendredi en janvier au matin
d'un côté profitant de cette inertie ou
de la longueur
une offensive ambitieuse des forces
terroristes d'un tsar eddine d'aqmi et
du milieu à eau qui pour la première
fois s'étaient regroupés et agissait
ainsi de façon concertée pour progresser
vers bamako et confisqué le territoire
malien à leur profit en face on peut le
dire une armée malienne en grande
difficulté qui n'avait pas la capacité
de résister à l'offensive des groupes
terroristes lancées vers la capitale
malienne ville ouverte si le verrou
était tombé
l'appel à l'aide du président malien a
corroboré l'urgence d'agir
telle qu'elle avait été évalué par un
service de renseignement et à déclencher
la prise de décision du président de la
république et donc l'intervention de nos
forces armées
cette intervention elle est donc je le
crois et personne ne le nie exemplaires
sur le fond car elle est raisonnée et
raisonnable
les objectifs de l'intervention décidée
par le président de la république sont
très claires
d'abord stopper l'offensive des
terroristes et les a empêché de menacer
la totalité de l'état malien ensuite
préservé cela va de soi l'intégralité
territoriale du mali assuré ne
l'oublions pas la sécurité des
ressortissants français et étrangers
notamment ceux qui sont aujourd'hui à
bamako
et enfin préparer et faciliter
l'application des résolutions du conseil
de sécurité prévoyant et ça va pas être
facile le renforcement de l'armée
malienne et le déploiement d'une force
d'intervention africaine chers collègues
sur les ministres les missions assignées
à nos forces armées sont d'utiliser les
frappes aériennes et le développement et
le déploiement d'éléments terrestre pour
atteindre ses objectifs
c'est ce qui est en train de se passer
en ce moment même sur le terrain le
président de la république a donné
toutes les instructions pour que les
moyens utilisés par la france soient
strictement limitées par rapport à ces
objectifs la france cela a été dit par
vous même monsieur le ministre des
affaires étrangères ne poursuit aucun
intérêt particulier autre que la
sauvegarde d'un pays ami et n'a pas
d'autre but que la lutte contre le
terrorisme
je comprends nous comprenons bien
évidemment l'accroissement de
l'inquiétude des familles des otages
retenus au sahel
je ne doute pas que la france reste et
restera déterminée et mobilisée pour
obtenir leur libération
mais sur ce point je me permettrai de
vous citer monsieur mise affaires
étrangères car cette déclaration est
éclairante pour tous ceux qui doutent
ce n'est pas en laissant le mali devenir
un sanctuaire terroriste que nous
protègerons les otages
le combat pour le mali le combat pour le
maintien de l'intégrité du mali est un
combat contre le terrorisme
en même temps et il va donc se
poursuivre il s'agit d'une mission
fondamentale qui s'inscrit dans la durée
et cela a été dit par le président la
république répéter ici même et qui
durera donc aussi longtemps que
nécessaire mais grâce à la rapidité de
décision du chef de l'état à la capacité
de réaction immédiate de nos armées qui
était en quelque sorte préparer la
france à créer une dynamique
internationale importante majeur pour
avancer dans la lutte contre le
terrorisme et vers la paix ce que nous
le voulons car
on fait la guerre il faut savoir
préparer la paix pour cela vous l'avez
dit la sortie ne peut être que politique
je sais que le président de la
république et vous même il travaillé et
la préparent comme le confirme sa
déclaration d'hier
je cite notre objectif est de faire en
sorte qu'il y ait une sécurité au mali
des autorités légitimes
un processus électoral et plus et plus
de terrorisme qui menace
j'ajoute que rien ne sera possible sans
qu une politique active de soutien
ensuite par l'union européenne au
développement de ce pays l'un des plus
pauvres du monde ne se mette en place
durablement pour terminer monsieur nice
des affaires étrangères chers collègues
je voudrais saluer ici dans cet
hémicycle
d'abord le ton qui a été employé par
utilisés par chacun des intervenants qui
dénote m'a-t-on dit avec le ton qui a pu
être employés par certains à l'assemblée
nationale
ici je salue et nous saluons le très
large rassemblement républicain qui
s'est créé tant au niveau des citoyens
français que des forces politiques
autour de cette intervention
au delà des positions politiques et des
clivages au delà des différences
la france est donc réuni aujourd'hui
autour de ces soldats qui combattent
aujourd'hui en ce moment sur le sol
malien contre les forces terroristes
c'est sans doute mes chers collègues ce
qui fait la grandeur d'un pays comme le
nôtre que de savoir se rassembler quand
il s'agit de défendre les valeurs de la
démocratie
je vous remercie
merci la parole est à monsieur le
président gérard larcher pour le groupe
ump
monsieur le président monsieur ministres
affaires étrangères dams et messieurs
les ministres je le dis d'emblée nous
nous tenons aujourd'hui aux côtés du
chef de l'état et de notre armée engagée
au mahdi comme tous mes autres collègues
à nos forces qui mène en première ligne
le combat sur un théâtre exigeant et
difficile
je veux dire ma totale confiance dans
leurs capacités face au courage de nos
soldats ils en ont déjà payé le prix
hommage leur soit rendue et à la mémoire
de damien boiteux oui grâce à leur
courage un coup d'arrêt a déjà été porté
à l'avancé et des terroristes des perce
pas figé nous savons nous avons affaire
à des terroristes
aguerri jeter corps et âme dans une
guerre asymétrique où il mène un combat
total mobile sur entraînés ils savent
utiliser ce désert au climat hostile
enclave escarpé propice à tous les
trafics immensité où ils peuvent se
diluer et s'abriter ils en ont fait leur
sanctuaire et leurs bases arrières ils
ont leur camp d'entraînement et
établissent leur collection avec
d'autres réseaux terroristes
la secte boko haram au nigeria le shebab
somaliens unsoj al charia ou obtenu si
aqmi en algérie il constitue
progressivement toute impunité inverse
tu as djihadistes de l'atlantique à la
mer rouge dans un continuum de trafic et
d'exactions qui va du sahel à la somalie
et monsieur le ministre des affaires
étrangères vous savez que tout ceci n'a
pas commencé qu'au début de la sphère
libyenne mais bien avant et qu'en 2010
certain nombre de chefs d'état et de
gouvernement de cette région attire l
attention de la france sur une émergence
j'allais dire au travers des trafics de
la montée en puissance de groupes
terroristes d'une déstabilisation qui
irait demain au nigeria mme disait-il en
2010 jusqu'au golfe de guinée
créée en quelque sorte le syndrome de la
somalie et au large des côtes de la
somalie nous devons donc regarder ce
phénomène comme un phénomène qui n'a pas
commencé il y a quelques mois où il y a
dix
oui moi mais depuis beaucoup plus
longtemps je ne reviendrai pas sur
l'importance de leur armement puisque il
ya certes les armes légères mais aussi
on le sait des missiles antichars milan
et si j'en crois une dépêche des
missiles sol-air sam-7 l'argent il y en
a grâce au trafic d'otages dont ils sont
fait une spécialité à la dîme prélevée
au passage de convois de trafiquants de
cigarettes d'essence et surtout de
cocaïne
car le réseau de la cocaïne ça n'est
plus madrid barajas comme il y a vingt
ans c'est aujourd'hui ceux de vastes
territoires du sahel pouvions nous
laisser aqmi devenir maître de la région
y faire prospérer avec mme zhao
notamment ses trafics pouvions nous
laisser les terroristes à servir tout un
peuple pour rire nous laisser se
continuer cet immense sanctuaire
djihadistes qui lui mali à la corne de
l'afrique en passant par le nigeria puis
le golfe de guinée s'étendrait
progressivement
oui la france a eu raison de vouloir
stopper l'avancée des terroristes oui la
france a eu raison d'empêcher
l'effondrement du mali et par effet de
souffle de toute la région
oui la france a raison de vouloir aider
la force africaine à restaurer
l'intégrité de ce pays oui la france a
raison de vouloir restaurer une légalité
constitutionnelle au mali pourtant la
situation des pas tout à fait celle que
nous avions imaginé à l'initiative du
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armées avec jean pierre chevènement
nous avons constitué à son initiative un
groupe sage nous avons commencé à
réfléchir et le scénario était un peu
différent à la fin du mois de novembre
et bien aujourd'hui face j'allais dire à
d'urgence à l'urgence
notre gouvernement le chef de l'état a
réagi et nous avons changé notre
planification
c'est l'honneur de la décision c'est
l'honneur de notre armée
moins de cinq heures après l'ordre
présidentiel au combat contre les 12 100
terroristes de cette colonne qui fondée
sur bamako durement éprouvée ces jours
derniers pourrait aussi rendre hommage à
nos services de renseignement durement
éprouvé
ces jours derniers qui ont su déceler la
menace avec précision et pertinence
alors est ce encore bon et françois
zocchetto l'on dit nous avons aussi des
interrogations
quelle sera l'ampleur de la phase
terrestre quelles seront ses
implications pour nos soldats que veut
dire tenir seul un territoire hostile
d'une telle immensité les difficultés
que nous rencontrons aujourd'hui pour
traiter le fuseau ouest augure-t-elle
d'une combativité supérieur à nos
prévisions
durée d'intervention et la guerre sans
fin ce serait le risque majeur
quel sera le degré de préparation des
groupes de la cedeao jean pierre
chevènement l'a évoqué nous savons que
il faudra des semaines pour qu'elle soit
au niveau opérationnel
quel est notre scénario de sortie
moi aussi comme le président de la
commission j'aimerais aujourd'hui dire
clairement aux rédacteurs du livre ben
hur la loi de programmation militaire en
préparation qu'il faut que nous
réfléchissions avant d'abandonner des
capacités avant de réduire des forces
prépositionnées forces spéciales
renseignements troupes au sol moyens
blindés moyens aériens
nous avons besoin de tout le spectre
n'oublions pas qu'il faut 72 heures un
bâtiment de la marine nationale pour
rejoindre le détroit d'ormuz je ne dis
pas ça tout à fait par hasard à partir
de toulon on voit bien aujourd'hui
l'importance de nos forces au tchad au
gabon sénégal dans la montée en
puissance du dispositif serval ce
pourrait être demain le cas vers
d'autres théâtres à partir des émirats
arabes unis
et si nous avions dû évacuer plusieurs
centaines voire plusieurs milliers de
nos ressortissants au mali au plan d'eau
de la côte d'ivoire
nous devons méditer ces enseignements et
de pas avoir simplement des
préoccupations que nous avons tous
financière comme variable d'ajustement
mais font dans notre action sur la
résolution 20 85
nous n'avons pas vocation à agir seul je
trouve que dans sa déclaration le
premier ministre a été très aimable avec
madame ashton
je le dis bien très aimable parce que
certes un certain nombre de nos
partenaires se sont engagés
soutien politique soutien moral mais
nous voyons bien que la grande absente
aujourd'hui c'est néanmoins l'europe
à une semaine de l'anniversaire du
traité de l'elysée où nous devons en
quelque sorte refonder sur la base du
traité de l'elysée j'allais dire ce qui
fait le socle de l'europe
nous ne pouvons que constater avec un
peu de tristesse que l'europe n'est
autre chose en cette matière qu'une
super ong ou une entreprise à
responsabilité limitée je crois que nous
devons les uns les autres dans notre
diversité poser cette question alors je
n'oublie pas pour conclure les deux
enjeux de long terme pour le mali
d'abord et je l'évoqué dans la
responsabilité qui avait été la sienne
avec henri de raincourt le développement
et la seule vraie solution durable
cent cinquante mille réfugiés de 130
mille déplacés vient encore accroître
les mots d'une des populations parmi les
plus pauvres de la planète
on a évoqué cette espérance de vie deux
fois dix ans de moins que la moyenne
chez nous
la moitié de la population avec moins de
deux dollars par jour
la désertification le réchauffement
climatique la perte du pastoralisme qui
est en train de déstructurer toutes ces
sociétés notamment au nord
et puis la nécessité d'avoir une
cohérence dans notre attitude face au
fondamentalisme religieux et à ses
multiples facettes qu'il s'agisse d'une
expression politique ou de moyens
terroristes
il n'ya pas vérité ici et erreurs
ailleurs la refondation démocratique du
mali est naturellement de ce deuxième
enjeu toutes ces populations ne partage
en fait des bambara aux touareg en
passant par les sons gagne les
berabiches que le fleuve niger est un
islam qui jusque là était modérée au
fond le nord et ceci a été évoquée a
toujours été oublié peu de route
peu d'écoles peu d'infrastructures
médicales peu de développement
économique et à chaque fois a été
fortement brutalisé pour ne pas utiliser
d'autres mots la reprise des
négociations un terme à dien est une
urgence
et ça ne doit pas être une fois de plus
des négociations qui n'aboutissent qu'à
des accords qui ne sont jamais
respectées
il faut une feuille de route il faut
reprendre le fil de la transition vers
les élections démocratiques
moi aussi comme françois rebsamen jeu
conclura avec une pensée toute
particulière et christian cambon l'a eu
pour nos otages et leurs familles
aujourd'hui dans l' angoisse mais si
nous n'avions pas agi alors les preneurs
d'otages aurait soumis tout un pays et
nous savons que le message ainsi qu'ils
seraient adressés serait un message au
contraire des valeurs qui sont les
nôtres il ya des valeurs sur lequel
ensemble dans notre diversité nous ne
devons pas transiger ce sont les valeurs
qui nous rassemblent dans cet hémicycle
aujourd'hui ce sont des valeurs que nous
portons ensemble et qui font me
semble-t-il l'honneur de notre
république
merci la parole est à madame leila aichi
pour le groupe écologiste
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mais ce président la commission
mes chers collègues
tout d'abord je tiens une nouvelle fois
au nom du groupe écologiste à présenter
mes condoléances à la famille du
lieutenant boiteux et à l'ensemble des
civils tués dans les opérations dans les
périodes de crise intense nos
compatriotes attendent des réponses
claires en ce sens le groupe écologiste
au sénat et moi-même reconnaissant la
licéité de l'intervention française au
mali au regard des relations bilatérales
entre nos deux pays et soutenant nos
femmes et nos hommes engagés dans cette
opération
toutefois au regard du droit
international
les trois résolutions votées à l'onu
2056 2071 2085 ouvre la voie à une
intervention internationale sous
responsabilité africaine et pouvant
faire usage de la force mais sans
implication directe de la france
il est donc urgent de nous conformer au
droit international
pour autant la clarté de notre décision
ne s'inscrit pas dans la simplification
à outrance ou à la caricature d'une
situation géopolitique très complexe
faire la guerre contre le terrorisme
partout où il se trouve est une
formulation trop stéréotypé voire
fausses pour appréhender de manière
exhaustive
une problématique malienne et régionales
multifactorielle et complexe je le
répète
souvenons nous du funeste exemple des
néoconservateurs américains et du
concept plus que douteux de la guerre
contre la terreur qu'elle a été l'année
la plus value de cette stratégie en irak
en 2003 et en afghanistan en termes de
sécurité
les populations civiles ne connaisse
hélas que trop bien le coût exorbitant
de telles idées d'ailleurs avons nous
les moyens d'une telle ambition
dans ce cas pourquoi ne pas tirer les
conséquences de vos analyses et
multiplier le budget de la défense par
cinq
de même je vous rappelle que nous
évacuons nos troupes d'afghanistan
après dix ans de guerre avec des
résultats plus que mitigés
pour ma part je ne souscris en rien au
concept du choc des civilisations
alors même que nous savons tous ici
qu'il s'agit essentiellement d'un
problème d'accès aux matières premières
et à l'énergie je ne crois pas non plus
au caractère irréconciliables du nord
mali touareg opposé au sud mali noir de
même l'antagonisme historique entre une
culture nomade et une culture
sédentaires ne doit pas être exagérée le
prétexte religieux souvent utilisé pour
des entreprises criminelles dont on sait
que l'essentiel est liée au trafic de
drogue et aux trafics d'armes ne peut en
aucun cas place au direct sur les
chaînes parlementaires nous interrompons
cette séance pour prendre la direction
de l'elysée ou françois hollande va
présenter ses voeux aux parlementaires
et plus précisément au bureau des
assemblées assemblée nationale-sénat
conseil économique social et
environnemental et conseil de paris on
écoute tout de suite le président de la
république mais je voulais d'abord salut